lupus is a disease in which your immune
system attacks the tissues in your own
body
your immune system is made up of white
blood cells that defend your body
against foreign invaders normally when
foreign invaders such as viruses and
bacteria get into your body some of your
white blood cells identify them as
foreign because they contain substances
called antigens
this recognition causes some of your
white blood cells to make chemical
markers called antibodies
these antibodies attach to the antigens
marking the foreign invaders as targets
for your immune system to destroy them
in an autoimmune disease such as lupus
your white blood cells mistakenly make
antibodies to mark some of your own body
cells and circulating chemicals for
destruction
when the antibodies attach to your
normal cells
your white blood cells begin to attack
them as if they were foreign antigens
time.this autoimmune response causes
inflammation in the parts of your body
wherever this attack is happening
inflammation makes the blood vessels in
the affected area expand and leak fluid
causing redness and swelling
the symptoms of lupus happen as your
immune system begins to attack different
areas of your body
you may develop a butterfly-shaped skin
rash on your cheeks and nose
small sores or ulcers may form inside
your nose or mouth
you may develop arthritis in which your
joints become inflamed and swollen
when your fingers are cold they may turn
a blue or white color this is called
Raynaud's phenomenon
you may have pain during deep breathing
caused by pleurisy a condition in which
the outer lining of your lungs is
inflamed
your white blood cells may create
antibodies that attach to bits of your
DNA from worn-out cells the attached
pair called an immune complex can lodge
in your kidneys and cause inflammation
this disorder is called lupus nephritis
flare-ups of any of your symptoms even
those not related to your skin may be
caused by an unusual reaction to
sunlight called photosensitivity
other common symptoms of lupus include
extreme fatigue headaches fever
a reduced number of red blood cells in
your blood called anemia
swelling of your legs feet hands or skin
around your eyes
muscle pain and weakness and hair loss
lupus is sometimes called the great
imitator because its many symptoms are
found in other health problems
there is no cure for lupus however you
may prevent or reduce flare-ups by
avoiding direct sunlight and wearing
sunscreen outside
the sunscreen should have a sun
protection factor of 55 or greater and
block both ultraviolet a and ultraviolet
B radiation
to treat your symptoms your doctor may
recommend a combination of drugs to
reduce inflammation such as
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs or
NSAIDs
and anti malarial drugs
your doctor may also recommend drugs
that suppress or prevent your immune
system from attacking the tissues in
your body such as corticosteroids